during the telecom council we agreed on
the use of the ultra high frequency bent
in the EU the 700 megahertz band for the
ever greater need for mobile internet
access by making that 700 mega has been
available for wireless internet services
in Europe by 2020 more people and
businesses can have broadband internet
access in the morning we also had a
policy debate on the essential part of
the digital single market strategy and
that's the modernization of the rules
for telecom companies the new rules will
have to meet the demands of a rapidly
changing technology and support the
infrastructure development that is
necessary for an economy in which almost
every activity depends on connectivity
and I'm pleased to say that we reached
within five months and it's very fast an
agreement on the portability regulation
this will allow consumers who have
subscribed to our acquired own online
content such as music games films or
sporting events access to that content
when they are in another country we had
a very good opportunity to discuss with
the council the most recent development
in the Commission's policy to boost
Europe's competitiveness at the next
European Council will report progress on
our combination initiative including the
single market strategy digital single
market and the capital market Julian of
course we we have started to deliver but
the most urgent think now is to as a
quick adoption of our of our proposals
we need more investment in ICT we need
to improve the function of product and
services market we need to remove
barriers to innovation of course but
also extremely important point we need
to address and we have to address the
skills short shortages in the vital
areas I welcome the proposed
competitiveness scoreboard which will
help us all to focus on the urgency of
the problems